el campo de batalla al búnker pasando
por reuniones con jefes de estado en los
últimos 10 meses volodimir selenski
parece haber estado en todas partes
desde la invasión rusa del 24 de febrero
el presidente ucraniano ha pronunciado
discursos a diario seguidos a escala
local y mundial y ese espíritu de lucha
sumado a su decisión de permanecer en
kiev y movilizar a su país hizo que la
revista Time lo eligiera como persona
del año el redactor jefe de taen Edward
fellsenthal dijo que la decisión de este
año era la más clara que se recuerda
su ofensiva informativa cambió El
Sistema Meteorológico geopolítico
desencadenando una ola de acción que
barrió el mundo al elegir la revista
afirmó que el presidente ucraniano había
demostrado que al resistir la invasión
rusa el coraje es contagioso el ex
cómico y actor que en una ocasión
interpretó a un presidente en un
programa de televisión ha demostrado ser
un experto en el arte de las redes
sociales al tiempo que lucha en una
guerra de información Pero ha habido
algunos pasos en falso por el camino la
portada de vogue en la que aparecía la
primera dama fue criticada por estar
fuera de lugar y algunos opusieron a las
sesiones de fotos de lujo mientras los
ucranianos sufrían los horrores de la
guerra los encuentros con famosos como
el actor estadounidense Ben stiller
también han sido objeto de críticas
selensky por su parte ha demostrado que
sabe cómo aprovechar estas visitas de
alto nivel para atraer la atención de
los medios de comunicación y mantener la
Guerra de Ucrania en los primeros pues
de la agenda informativa mundial su
incesante búsqueda de titulares puede
enfadar algunos pero garantiza que
Ucrania rara vez deje de ser el centro
de atención y esa puede acabar siendo la
mayor victoria de zelanski